[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous alors avant de faire le
col tall que je vais me présenter un
petit peu donc je m'appelle vivien
gaulier et je suis en situation de
handicap moteur et gère un syndrôme
cérébelleux donc un syndrôme cérébelleux
c'est un syndrome qui touche mon
cervelet une partie du cerveau qui sert
à la coordination et à la clim donc
tenir par exemple tenir sur une sur une
jambe
vous voyez que je suis un peu bancal
donc voilà voilà en quoi constitue mon
handicap et donc je me suis demandé un
jour avec les avancées de la science et
des technologies émergentes avancé
conjuguée au mythe de la recherche de
l'homme parfait
on peut imaginer que le handicap n'est
maladie des génériques et autres types
de problèmes disparaîtront dans les
prochaines décennies
mais ce scénario il ya plus de la
spéculation que de la réalité
je vais essayer un bleu mans de vous
convaincre que les personnes en
situation de handicap peuvent apporter
une chance pour l'avenir
en effet le handicap et la technologie
ont toujours eu une relation très
particulière et aujourd'hui encore cette
relation à plusieurs facettes
premièrement les personnes à bien et
fils y ait en premier dès des progrès
techniques notamment en domotique en
robotique et en décennies avec notamment
les membres bionique les les nous les
fauteuils roulants les prothèses sont
les personnes handicapées
il y a aussi chez les transhumanisme et
notamment cette techno progressiste
ligue et une idée selon laquelle les
personnes en situation de handicap
seront les premières personnes a
bénéficié de l'augmentation via la
technologie avec eux tout ce que je veux
je vous ai parlé membres bionic et
prothèses on peut citer pour exemple
pour illustrer cette ce que je viens
dire le handisport et notamment
l'athlétisme chez les valides
la question qu'on se pose depuis
plusieurs années c'est est ce que
l'homme va couvrir un jour le à un [ __ ]
donc 42 kg mais athée quelques en moins
de deux heures des expériences non
conformes aux règles ont été quand tenté
peu concluantes
alors que et grâce aux fauteuils
roulants sportif les personnes en
situation de handicap peuvent le court
et en 1h20 dans un sport qui ressemble
plus à du vélo que vraiment à de la
course à pied mais voilà pour vous dire
que grâce à l'amélioration des
technologies et des méthodes
d'entraînement de ces sportifs notamment
dans les domaines de sprint de longueur
de saut on boit peu les athlètes amputés
et handicapés pourront bientôt je le
pense être plus performants que les
personnes valides et plus télégénique
peut-être peut-être on aura les jeux
paralympiques
avant les jeux olympiques le contraire
de maintenant mais d'un autre côté on
voit une un mouvement se crée des
mentalités évoluent et des communautés
se former aujourd'hui est partout dans
le monde
plus il ya de plus en plus de mal
entendants et de nom en tendant qui se
refuse qu'ils refusent catégoriquement
de se faire de se faire implanter des
implants pour mieux entendre des
appareils pour mieux entendre
l'appareillage auditif
ces appareils sont plus on observe plus
à leur donner des repères sonore cas
vraiment leur rendre louis mais selon
elle les refusent et ce n'est pas par
les eaux du bismes donc par refus de la
technologie mais par appartenance à une
communauté je laisse mon texte
il sert à rien parce que au fil des
siècles les sourds et les malentendants
avec notamment la langue des signes ont
construit et ont conçu leur propre
langage leurs propres à leur propre
cinéma leur propre culture et c'est
cette culture qui veulent démontrer au
monde et par exemple je vais prendre un
truc tout bête
ils possèdent leurs propres jeux
paralympiques c'est à dire que ils ont
ils ont créé des défilés aux pique des
jeux olympiques uniquement réservé aux
sourds et aux malentendants
donc maintenant ils nous disent qu'ils
ne sont plus handicapé mais qu'ils sont
différents
vous voyez la nuance ce mouvement peut
se rapprocher des mouvements
d'émancipation par exemple du mouvement
de droits des femmes ou de vue ou des
mouvements d'émancipation pour les
droits aux minorités de couleur par
exemple les noirs américains en amérique
ou encore les lgbt
plus récemment les autistes ont aussi
créé leur mouvement de protestation et
de revendication d'euros droits civiques
la neuro diversité étymologie rappelant
la biodiversité qu'il faut à tout prix
conserver ce mouvement des droits
civiques prenant pour symbole le sigle
infinie et le drapeau arc-en-ciel est
similaire aux malentendants dans de
nombreux points ils ne veulent plus être
considéré comme handicapé mais comme
différent et veulent continuer à
développer leur propre culture
de plus l'autisme a une place importante
dans le développement de l'intelligence
artificielle selon des experts leurs
cerveaux qui serait beaucoup plus
enclins à avoir une meilleure mémoire et
une meilleure créativité peut nous aider
à résoudre les problèmes que nous cause
est développée surtout les intelligences
artificielles et les comprendre par
exemple dans la silicon valley où il ya
notamment des
des grandes entreprises de développement
de la technologie et de et dans là aussi
avec des disney tout ça on veut passer
de deux minutes
autisme qui travaille actuellement à 100
milles voilà notamment chez microsoft
pour leur recherche en intelligence
artificielle mais ce qui est bien dans
le terme de neuro diversité c'est qu'il
est ouverte
par exemple les autistes louvre aux
personnes qui ont des toques et des
problèmes c'est chic
il ouvre aussi au potentiel émotionnel
ou au potentiel intellectuel
à l'instar de beaucoup de pays ces
enfants ne sont pas reconnus comme
enfant pouvant développer des handicaps
social on dit au potentiel intellectuel
et au potentiel émotionnel c'est le type
de à plus de 132 depuis que tout le
monde va imaginer prix nobel de physique
ou medal 6 dans quelques années alors
que non en fait ces enfants là ont un
cerveau qui qui tourne aussi vite qu'une
usine et sont perdus des fois dans leurs
pensées qui peut entraîner un manque de
confiance en soi un manque de
compréhension de la société et des
normes sociales un mode d'organisation
dans les choses simples et comme les
personnes avec un qi inférieur de soi à
soixante dix les déficients
intellectuels une petite faiblesse
psychique
donc voilà pour dire que le terme neuro
diversité à des amis en fait les autisme
ont des amis qui englobe dans ce terme
ne re diversité et par exemple je vais
vous dire un truc ils ont une insulte
pour qualifier les personnes normales
neurotypiques donc par exemple vous dans
la salle
vous vous êtes tous neurotypiques là je
viens de vous insulter
donc j'espère que ça se passera bien
après entre nous d'accord je m'excuse
auparavant si je j'ai six jeux dans la
salle il n'ya d'oeneo road speak assuré
excusez moi du fait je ne voulais pas
vous vous perturber dans votre
neurotoxicité mais bon
mais le spectre du handicap et veut est
vaste et peut donner le vertige et
quelquefois paradoxal ou contradictoires
toutes les choses positives sur la
différence que je viens de vous énumérer
et de vous raconter en étant plus en
disant que c'était une chance pour tous
et pour l'avenir car ils n'ont pas la
même vision du monde que nous et que
cette vision du monde peut nous apporter
peut nous permettre de nous améliorer et
d'avoir un nom monde meilleur et un
futur désirable ne reflètent qu'une
partie du spectre du handicap
les malentendants les malvoyants certain
autisme
car sur les autistes 70 sont déficients
intellectuels et cap colin son hôte son
nom antheaume donc ne peuvent pas se
débrouiller seul mais pour les
polyhandicapés ceux qui ont une
déficience intellectuelle
combiné à un handicap physique cela peut
aussi entraîner leur entourage à être
dans la misère et dans l'hymne isolement
c'est malheureusement ce qui se passe
pour beaucoup de familles en france
alors qu'ils ont comme tout le monde dès
les mêmes droits les le droit aux
vacances les droit à une vie sociale
libre droit d'aller boire un verre à
grenoble où vous dans ou dans des lieux
branchés partout en france
donc voilà il faut aussi que notre
société elle ses parents et ces
personnes à ce que le handicap ne soit
pas un poids ou la foire dope pour
conclure et pour essayer avec vous de
construire un futur durable pour l'homme
nous faut radicalement changé notre
vision du handicap qu'ils ne soient pas
les erreurs qu'il faut à tout prix
corriger mais plus mais plus la petite
chose en moins qui peu à peu a apporté
une petite chose en plus
comme illustre très bien tiré lannister
dans la série super connue game of
thrones c'est peut-être pas le meilleur
personnage à l'épée mais à mon avis il
sait se débrouiller en charisme et et en
humour ou encore dans cette même série
bran qui pourra plus marcher mais à qui
on a promis de volée et pour finir
j'aimerais vous vous citez en asperger
donc le nom asperger ça devrait vous
rappeler quelque chose c'est comme henry
ford ii on sait à peu près ce qu'ils ont
inventé qui dit que tout ce qui est
anormal et donc qui sort de la norme
n'est pas nécessairement intérieur je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]